karine bechet bullough commercy d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
emmanuel macron a donc affiché sa
proximité avec svetlana tirano sky à
elle a été invitée à un renvoi rencontre
et on le disait le 7 octobre les députés
français alors pourquoi la france selon
vous semble si actif dans le dossier
biélorusses ont soit la france est
active dans dossier bill russe parce
qu'il faut bien que quelqu'un fasse ce
travail sur le devant la scène
si l'on en croit les résultats dit
renseignement extérieur russe cela fait
des années que la cia et le département
d'état au travail
la société sils biélorusse financer
couple skull de positions qui sont
formés en géorgie en ukraine en pologne
et dans les pays baltes mais il est
évident que sur ce dossier les etats
unis ne peuvent pas agir directement
donc il faut des personnages parlant
pour jouer ce rôle
manifestement macro on se sent
parfaitement à l'aise dans le rôle donc
il tient le devant la scène
c'est ce que l'on appelle normalement de
l'ingérence alors justement de son côté
le président russe un parle de pressions
extérieures son précédent tout en
rappelant la longue histoire on l'a
entendu unissant les deux pays
alors en quoi ce paramètre est important
à prendre en compte dans la gestion du 2
du dossier biélorusse la biélorussie et
la russie sont deux pays frères qui ont
une histoire millénaire communaux cela
fait quelques années qu'ils sont séparés
par les aléas l'histoire et la chute de
l'urss
sinon c'est le fait quand même
millénaire que c'est le même peuple donc
à toucher la biélorussie c'est aussi
touché la russie comme l'ukraine était
un des peuples frères de là aussi
historiquement maintenant c'est le tour
de la biélorussie nous sommes dans le
car une crise mondiale globale le clan
globaliste a besoin pour pouvoir être le
baliste de couvrir l'ensemble des
acteurs donc il faut faire tomber la
russie pour faire tomber la russie il
faut attaquer l'espace qui est autour
d'elle
c'est le tour de la biélorussie et
d'ailleurs on voit très bien que
le combat n'a bénéficié de la russie
sont complètement liés puisque à chaque
fois que ce soit la commission
européenne où que ce soit macro quand il
s'agit de la question des lots russe
parallèlement l'on parle également de la
question de nava ni contre la rustique
ces deux dossiers sont parfaitement liés
dans une même attaque menée actuellement
pour reprendre le contrôle du territoire
restant alors en tout cas le président
français a affirmé l'importance d'un
dialogue avec la russie pour une
transition en douceur en biélorussie
selon vous les deux chefs d'état
peuvent-ils s'accorder sur ce point et à
quelles conditions
si la russie s'accordent sur ce point
avec la france et qui parle donc non du
monde globaliste elle se promet le même
avenir que l'ukraine donc mans pour
l'instant tout cas je ne pense pas à
tant que poutine se re pouvoir qu'un
quelconque accord puisse être trouvé
si transition il doit y avoir c'est au
peuple biélorusse d'en décider ce n'est
certainement pas à macro de faire nous
avons vu déjà l'écran de réussite de sa
diplomatie au liban nous voyons général
sur les terrains où il intervient il et
se tape pour la biélorussie qu'elle
n'accepte pas et pour l'instant
effectivement la majorité ne semble pas
prête à accepter ce genre de choses
alors l'organisation pour la sécurité et
la coopération en europe va elle tenter
une médiation une initiative à laquelle
vladimir poutine a manifestement donné
son accord
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko acceptera-t-il de participer
à cette médiation visiblement compliqué
d'après ce que vous nous dites terminé
son est pour le moins compliquée puisque
pour qu'il y ait une médiation qui ait
un sens il faut qu'il puisse y avoir un
accord or là elle peut pas y ait encore
un accord puisque c'est un choix qu'il
faut faire soit c'est le choix des monts
globalis unilatérale défendu par
l'occident l'occurrence porté par ma
cour sur le plan européen
soit c'est un monde multilatéral porté
par la russie et poutine
en ce qui concerne le reste je vous
rappelle qu'elle avait déjà joué ce
merveilleux rôle de médiation en ukraine
en 2004 en 2014
en 2004 à l'époque de la révolution
orange c'est effectivement sous l'égide
de l'eau et ce qui a été organisé le
troisième tour des élections électorales
et c'est sous l'égide de l'ess
qui a été totalement détruit dans un
premier temps le système politique
ukrainien avec les conséquences des
rires du maiden que nous connaissons
alors justement est ce que concrètement
on peut attendre d'eux après cette
médiation qui conduite par le sc eu de
nouvelles élections d'ici la fin de
l'année comme la vie tirana svetlana est
un hoax callas pour qui l'on arrive à de
nouvelles élections avant la fin d'année
il faut que le cas chez coop partent
pour l'instant l'inauguration de luca
chaîne pourra lieu même si à déplaît
profondément en occident tout ce qui a
pu sortir anoska sont des déclarations à
l'étranger une espèce de parodie
fantasque à l'intérieur du pays
ça fait quand même pas très sérieux si
maintenant chaque personne qui conteste
une élection peut elle demander
l'organisation d'un 3e tour la remise en
cours de ces élections c'est la fin en
soi et du système politique et et du
système des états puisque dans ce cas la
légitimité ne viendra pas du processus
électoral et de l'élection des peuples
mais de la volonté la décision la
communauté internationale c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce qu'ils
demandaient exigé par le moule valide ce
qui n'a sûrement pas besoin de la
légitimité des états qui a si renoncent
à leur souveraineté donc à leur
existence
merci avoue karine bêcher golovkov
d'avoir partagé votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moscou